[Applauso]
[Musica]
Buonasera sul disordine mi presento così
l'altro giorno cercavo le chiavi di casa
e mi sono accorta che non avevo il
portafoglio e portafoglio poteva essere
in auto Quando avevo tirato fuori tutto
dalla borsa per cercare allora le chiavi
di casa ma per uscire a cercare il
portafoglio mi servivano le chiavi di
casa e a quel punto anche le chiavi
della macchina e non avevo entrambi No
però questo non è neanche il mio
problema principale il mio problema
principale è un altro ed è la
disregolazione emotiva Che cos'è
è come cercare un baricentro stando in
bilico su una capocchia di Spillo No
perché ora è il carnevale di Rio de
Janeiro in testa festa grande Poi Boom è
novembre in Transilvania colori spenti
ululati di pensieri in testa no e
intorno non è cambiato nulla Ma è
cambiato tutto e ovviamente non sono
l'unica a cui cambia la percezione della
vita cioè prendete un marciapiede in
città Ci sono giorni in cui lo vedete
come un brulicare di gente indaffarate
Cioè guarda quella cappellino strano
quel bambino paffutello e due giorni che
sono solo cacca di piccione no sigarette
spente una grondaia rotta cioè come
guardiamo la nostra vita La mattina non
è come la vediamo a mezzogiorno
immaginatevi solo dislivelli più alti
la disregolazione emotiva appartiene a
un disturbo e disturbo è sinonimo di
disordine il disturbo borderline in
italiano nel parlato dice Ah quello è
Borderline per dire è mezzo pazzo No non
mezzo perché il disturbo borderline si
porta dietro tutta una serie di
disordini tra quei disordini alimentari
che certificano la mia competenza a
parlare di disordine delle emozioni e
controllo delle emozioni ora che persino
Ma ricordo ha capito che l'ordine
materiale non è tutto
voi Avete presente tutti immagino Marie
kondo Il magico potere del riordine è un
best seller mondiale Poi è diventato una
serie TV Ebbene che è successo che alla
nascita dei figli il guru mondiale
dell'ordine abbandona l'ordine per
accogliere la vita
fatto che Ma ricorda mi ha privilegiato
i suoi figli ad arrotolare i calzini ci
rende felici per tutta la famiglia però
ce la dobbiamo immaginare prima di
questo Cioè se noi dobbiamo immaginare
quando
in qualche modo si disperava per non
poter arrotolare tutti i calzini Forse
ha pianto per l'impossibilità di farlo e
forse ha detto la mia vita Un disastro
No per tre pennarelli a terra ci ha
fatto quello e facciamo tutte l'ottava
per l'immagine che aveva della sua vita
per come l'aveva immaginata E infine ha
colto la vita come per tutti disordinata
anche per Marie kondo cioè che
probabilmente anche alzato un figlio No
se l'è portata al petto e tu mi da Gioia
Allora me lo tengo a me il disturbo non
mi dà gioia per niente però me lo tengo
lo stesso
e vorrei vedere con voi quali sono le
caratteristiche di questo disturbo
perché mi sono domandata nei tempi che
viviamo Sono Borderline Allora la oltre
alla disregolazione emotiva il primo è
impulsività
diciamo ce n'è in giro no Il secondo è
difficoltà a gestire la rabbia la
situazione internazionale la lasciamo
stare però ci bastano gli esercizi Troll
No per dire che la gestione della rabbia
forse è un problema di tempi
poi abbiamo picchi emotivi Non so voi
però cerchiamo picchi Motivi tutto il
giorno no Le piattaforme on demand
l'hanno capito il mercato l'ha capito ma
per rimanere nel piccolo qualcuno di voi
leggerà qualcuno di voi il giornale
online la mattina c'è qualcuno che lo
legge sulla sola sulla sola Vabbè
qualcuno la legge Va bene allora chi lo
legge con me e passa come me no da una
bottiglia di design raffinatissimo di
profumo a un eccidio a dei biscotti di
bontà irresistibile no È come se il
nostro sistema nervoso fosse
continuamente terremotato da scosse e
noi che facciamo facciamo quello che ci
riesce meglio come specie stando a
Darwin ci adattiamo ci adattiamo come
contraendo il muscolo dell'empatia
chiamiamolo così che ha bisogno dello
spazio vuoto del tempo di riflessione
per non atrofizzarsi No però
picchi motivi senza elaborazione come i
Borderline mi pare che ci stanno poi
abbiamo senso di vuoto tipo
un'aspirapolvere ti risucchia lo stomaco
Allora senso di vuoto in realtà il vuoto
Non ce l'abbiamo no abbiamo ce ne siamo
inventati così tanto che avanziamo nel
pieno come in una giungla e non abbiamo
il tempo nemmeno di riallineare le
priorità perché tempo noi non ce
l'abbiamo e quindi alla fine molti di
noi finiscono un po' gonfi di tutto con
gran senso di vuoto e poi ci abbiamo
pioggia di pensieri Questo è il motivo
per cui io perdo tutto in certi giorni
allora è peggio di pensieri diciamo
senza soste senza memoria
i nostri pensieri cambiano oggetto a una
velocità mai accaduta prima al cervello
della nostra specie
i pensieri andavano anche veloci
sull'Altopiano dell'Etiopia quando
scappavamo dal leone lì andavano
velocissimo però erano indirizzati ad un
unico scopo quello di sopravvivere
mentre Adesso è a uno scopo più
molteplice quello va sotto il nome di
vivere meglio e noi associamo il vivere
meglio a un senso di padronanza sulla
nostra vita Un po' come se l’homo
Sapiens avesse percorso tutta la sua
storia fin qua mosso da un irrefrenabile
bisogno di controllo No Qual è la mia
media dei battiti cardiaci al minuto
Oggi com'è il meteo fra 15 giorni
non so chi le usa ma ci sono app per
controllare il sonno Io per esempio non
la voglio l'app per controllare il sonno
l'algoritmo Non lo vuol capire e quindi
si sentisse mi sono ritrovata domani ma
sono andata in apnea stanotte no perché
fa succedere proprio così che il
controllo ci risette nell'ansia E
l'ansia da controllo ce l'abbiamo tutti
persino io che non ho praticamente
controllo di nulla ce l'ho avuta ad
esempio a preparare questo Ted ne ho
scritti 6 Li ho buttati tutti prima ho
tormentato gli organizzatori con tre Ted
a contenuto diverso che sono stati
approvate sono stati buttati e questo è
il mio primo e Settimo Ted e loro stanno
pensando fra 4 minuti questa schioda E
noi siamo Salvi però quando non c'è il
Ted io esercito mi avanza dal controllo
geolocalizzato in continuazione neanche
se fosse Cristoforo Colombo sulla Santa
Maria mi cioè perché geolocalizzarmi mi
dà senso di padronanza e nei giorni
proprio Neri quando la pioggia di
pensieri Io geolocalizzo anche il
bancomat ristoranti e le pensioni gli
hotel tutto del posto dove sono diretta
sempre per il benedetto senso di
padronanza e notate che io cerco il
senso padronanza proprio perché non ne
ho alcuno no
questo per dirvi cosa per dirvi
che forse il controllo adesso ce lo
lasciamo un attimo da parte così ambiguo
No nel dare nel togliere e parliamo di
qualcosa di cui avete sentito parlare
finora cioè l'opposto il caos
Ecco sapete ormai benissimo che caos
vuol dire nel suo etimo essere aperto
spalancato e che per gli antichi Greci
il caos era descritto proprio come una
nera gola spalancata
apparsa nell'eternità all'improvviso e
vediamo un attimo di cosa è stato capace
di fare questa nera gola spalancata
perché la nera con la spalancata apparsa
all'improvviso
coincide con quello che la scienza
millenni dopo chiamerà il tempo di
Planck cioè il primissimo stadio della
nascita dell'universo e la nostra
possibilità di esistere inizia proprio
con una nera gola spalancata
questo vi può a turbarezziamo subito
così riacquistiamo senso di padronanza
è vero però cioè non sarà la più dai una
geolocalizzazione più esatta che avete
visto in vita vostra questo ve lo
concedo però è comunque reale No noi
siamo qui cioè è reale quanto la visione
piccola a cui ci induce la tecnologia
e
questo diciamo
di essere qui in questa bellezza che ha
13 miliardi e 700 milioni di anni ci
accomuna come ci accomuna il fatto che
abbiamo a disposizione un tempo più
corto no dei 13 miliardi e 700 milioni
di anni e per quanto ci affagniamo
calcoliamo statistiche lavoriamo dati
non possiamo veramente scegliere il
segmento di tempo che chiameremo nostro
e che abitiamo o probabilmente saremo
qui da tutte le aree della storia No Là
c'è il signore del Neolitico la il
monaco medievale perché nessuno avrebbe
veramente schiodato forse pochissimi e
visti però da questa prospettiva sia
temporale che spaziale Noi siamo
frattali cioè geometrie ripetute nel
tempo su scala diversa Siamo come la
Cimetta del broccolo romano Il rametto
dell'abete che non abbiamo idea e
percezione della complessità della
pianta a cui apparteniamo tutti e questa
inconsapevolezza ci accomuna l'altra
cosa che ci accomuna è che in questo
segmento di tempo che chiamiamo nostro
siamo abitati dal caos delle nostre
emozioni
non stringersi della gola un contrarsi
dello stomaco il cuore che si fa quello
di un due Noi lo chiamiamo dolore al di
là delle cause che attribuiamo a quel
sentire al di là della narrazione che
facciamo di quel sentire ecco chi ha un
disturbo come il mio prova quelle
sensazioni
in assenza di eventi e
si chiama disturbo perché disturba la
vita perché la intralcia e a un certo
punto mi sono detta Ma io cioè cosa ne
faccio di tutta questa montagna di tempo
disturbata perché la volevo Come
recuperare no mi sono domandata come la
posso usare questa
già facendomi la domanda mi sono accorta
che mi sentivo un po' meno schiacciata
perché
mi ero messa in cerca e mettersi in
cerca è un atto di Potenza No ero
passata da una posizione passiva ad una
attiva e voleva assolutamente usarla
questa potenza che sentivo nel mio
sistema nervoso nei muscoli contratti
Cioè era c'era un lavoro
ed era sicuramente energia nera ma
energia
al momento che ho fatto questo cambio di
prospettiva cosa è successo È successo
che alla soglia dei 50 anni io mi dicevo
è andata così no non avevo più il lavoro
e non una relazione altamente
disfunzionale ero Completamente priva di
speranza poi mi sono allenata a una
pensiero nuovo uno soltanto e se oggi
sono su questo palco a parlarvi È
proprio grazie alla potenza che ho
sviluppato In cosa ci faccio perché è
incredibile come
i nostri pensieri ci scrivano
letteralmente No la l'auto narrazione
che facciamo di noi scrive il corso dei
nostri eventi e questo perché Perché i
pensieri sono ciò che detta il corpo il
modo di reagire alle cose e quindi
ancora più incredibile come ci siamo
evoluti fino a qua per non prestare
assolutamente attenzione alla qualità e
all'allenamento Che facciamo con i
nostri pensieri
per cui vi invito a immaginare il dolore
come un Ciocco di legno pesante grosso
non c'è vita che non è debba trasportare
uno perché anche l'evento più
prevedibile e naturale di tutti la
perdita del proprio genitore è un Ciocco
di legno pesante da trasportare no si
può subire si può scagliare contro
qualcuno
oppure ci si può imparare accendere il
fuoco per
sviluppare tutta la nostra potenza nella
nostra forma nella nostra natura e usare
tutta la nostra potenza di questa nostra
comune occasione Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]